hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry so
it's early in the morning but we got
together today to talk about something
I've been wanting charity for quite some
time now neill blomkamp is getting the
next alien movie going that's right now
prometheus 2 not some spin off its the
actual alien franchise going to continue
first off I love how he did it I think
the best way to get any real passion
project off the ground if you want to do
like a reboot or sequel is how they did
Street Fighter legacy they did the
mortal kombat short films on youtube and
stuff I thought it was cool that he just
made up some designs and was like I'm
just gonna post this on Instagram and
see how people respond I don't know that
all the circumstances behind that
because he put them up it was like I
guess this isn't gonna get made so here
you go here's the concept aren't anyway
just just cuz it's cool yeah and then
people were like oh no maybe it should
get made like oh dude but it literally
look great it looked horrifying like the
big Queen alien image that he drew up it
looks terrifying well there's a big
space station and there's a yeah and
there's a shake old bean yeah michael
biehn like where's the photo michael and
yeah they have a updated photo of
michael biehn going on here and I think
it's cool that he's returning because
visit died yeah that's what you said is
that he's returning well that's not
official but he wants the character
shuri-chan there was a fuss for a while
that he was like Superman returning this
thing like oh he's gonna ignore alien 3
anymore and just to pick up from there
but he specifically said he's not going
to disregard those phones yeah he said
that he just wants it to be like the
sibling to aliens yeah because you know
what most people like alien and aliens
but they're not a big fan of alien 3 and
resurrection those movies do have like
small followings here and there hmm yeah
you know like alien 3 I know wasn't
well-received like at all but I thought
it was okay there are people it shot
really well I know it's like David
Fincher's one not
really recommended film I thought it was
kind of cool okay and i thought it was
shot really well alien resurrection sure
has a lot of problems it's definitely
not the best one out of the four but
decent i guess it's vile and that's for
sure but aliens though that's one hell
of a [ __ ] film right there well yeah
and you have that whole tonal shift
because the first movie is very sort of
dready and suspenseful in the second
movie is like there's so much like
action and badassery see he said he
wants to kind of do like a hybrid of
that when he was describing sounded a
lot more akin to alien with all the like
psychological like I think even so like
Freudian stuff yeah and then having it
be sort of like a cat mouse you know he
said it's like a traditional monster
film but with like really cool of alien
effects and stuff yeah and weird
psychology yeah exactly but you know
neill blomkamp also knows how to do like
that's what was cool about James Cameron
because James Cameron if knew how to do
action films really well you know he has
like terminator two hundred bell true
lies he is the perfect director to take
over because you know like we've all
seen his designs what I like how he's
because i liked Elysium I did I respect
the fact that he admitted that it could
have been better yeah yeah it's not
without its you know blemishes and
whatnot and I like how he didn't like
blame the studios for that like he is he
was taking responsibility if I saying
the script wasn't fully done like wasn't
at its best yet but they made it anyway
I feel like he's not gonna make the same
mistake twice like that especially alien
I feel like he's going to do a greater
you know I haven't seen chappie yet but
Sigourney Weaver's in that yeah so I
imagine they have like a puma Thurman
Tarantino thing going on where they just
started talking about alien and what
they think they could do next with it
well that's what she said I mean yeah
you know his ideas like they started
talking about their ideas and she had
wanted to return to it and she said like
it's sort of seemed i guess like it was
meant to be you know like that we would
wait so long and then find oh this is
the right guy to do it well he updated a
like alien world with district nine like
he brought it to a new dimension oh yeah
he brought something different at least
the kind of sci-fi movies were used to
seeing lately oh you know it was
only different grimy and you have not
like it's so cool but the point is not
cool it's in a swan then it's you know
and this or even this my god like I
don't know how much bigger he's gonna
make the alien world because he because
he does like he creates worlds and you
know like he's what i love about neill
blomkamp is a story first like it's all
about story first and then the designs
and action is all there it's all always
very cool but its secondary to the story
I mean I feel like they're just both
interlocked with each other because
there's a whole lot of world building
and design and all that so I mean it's
just so intrinsically what he does it
seems like yeah but he doesn't strike me
as a director who's gonna go like all
Peter Jackson or nothing yet all caught
up in effects he strikes me as someone
who will just actually still honor the
character still on his story yeah what's
cool about this is it's the first sequel
he's doing I know he didn't do any of
the other ones but this is clearly
derived from the stalled a place of love
for alien yeah and so I'm really excited
to see someone take that love for the
franchise and really implement it
because I've never havin teen him do
that yet like pick up a franchise and be
like it it's like we've almost seen him
do that much times it seems like this is
the right one because like there were
rumors like who is he gonna direct the
hobbit muzu is he gonna drink Star Wars
I would have been interested to see
those but I feel like alien is like a
nice place for him to go because alien
is a little more in with the characters
as well as design it just seems like it
fits his sensibilities more than
something like The Hobbit or Star Wars
worth like shiny well yeah he knows
something very like awesome sci-fi
worlds the alien at least he on the
first alien movie isn't as much of like
ah I feel like he's gonna tie it all in
because it does the alien movies do you
deserve a good conclusion because the
Alien Resurrection doesn't fully wrap up
the story it takes place like hundreds
of years later well then you've got
clone Ripley oh it's yeah exactly and
she's like super hero style but I think
this is they want to wrap up real humid
Ridley well they want to bring the story
to a close like I heard there's a photo
that kind of resembles the original
alien ship you know you're bringing back
Michael
or at least the character they're trying
to bring back I can't imagine he
wouldn't do it yeah like it's just it
feels like he can expand upon the
universe yeah yeah you know seems like
the guy for this job like it's he's
saying he wants to close I'm a little
concerned that it's gonna do so well
that studios were like let's continue
this franchise cuz I like the idea that
they're not trying to reboot it but he's
trying to put a good final chapter on
yeah he's Rocky Balboa ng the [ __ ] it's
that fun fact rocky Balboa's gonna make
a comeback and Creed that's right yeah
he's relaying Rocky like drapeau never
gonna not ready I love the new designs
that he has the concept art I think that
you know like he's someone who knows how
to deliver on thrills and suspense but
he's never really done horror he sounds
like he wants to bring alien back to
horror territory yeah yeah I know I
would love to see his take on like
sci-fi horror too yeah cuz he all his
films are like district 9 is like sci-fi
drama mockumentary and then elysium's
like sci-fi action film dystopian world
chappie is another sci-fi film yeah and
then this way yes I and that's like
sci-fi there's sci-fi with with you know
human elements and stuff yeah that's
what easy to have a brain that's what
he's great at doing is bringing humanity
to these roles yeah I'm just excited to
see him do it and sharlto copley is
gonna be playing the alien was even it's
good sailor show network yeah i heard
they met when they were like really
young and they help each other out of
their careers well yeah cuz like sharlto
copley has done so many jobs like I
guess he used to produce for people and
he used to like run this game show yeah
I would love to see sharlto copley in
this oh he would fit in somewhere I'm
sure he could visit me every cameras
he's perfect and he him in neill
blomkamp work perfectly together yeah I
mean there's alum they're like the
[ __ ] Kurt Russell John Carpenter
Scorsese De Niro Scorsese DiCaprio
Johnny Depp Tim Burton over the sci-fi
world you know like they're perfect
together yeah i'm hoping sharlto copley
zimbali is definitely he should play
Ripley yeah rendition doc Sigourney
Weaver out and
Sigourney Weaver will mo capaldi alien
yeah yeah Sigourney Weaver was like this
[ __ ] is Ripley you know in the first one
she's a terrified woman who has to
really go against her fears and survive
and the session he's also really strong
character in that movie though yeah I
know she becomes stronger as the film
progresses to she's not weak she starts
off strong yeah but you know it's a
story of survival in the second one I
love how she starts off like traumatized
and she has to face her trauma that was
great and then in third and fourth one
she just can't seem to get away from
these usually yes it just keeps going
wrong for her he was getting surrounded
by these preachers that just happened to
stumble upon her I'm hearing he's trying
to wrap it full circle so maybe there
would be like an alien war that happens
or something you know because we haven't
seen an alien movie really take place on
earth yet hahaha and that well that
would be pretty neat decision
I'm hoping with Neill Blomkamp's um
alien film that they go back to
practical effects yeah yeah like that's
one thing I respected about the second
alien vs predator granted sucked but the
effects were still kind of cool is
before dude those four dudes were like
we're gonna do it right do it correctly
they just made horse they had a good
approach in certain as a great Jen
shanks yeah yeah the effects were cool
as courses in it so yeah I'm hoping that
they at least because I know these
concept designs are like animated so I'm
hoping that they go back to practical
effects though because the Queen aliens
[ __ ] terrifying yeah I cuz it's
practical effects yeah it's scarier than
[ __ ] alien vs predator when it's CG I
was running after them I think he's a
filmmaker would probably appreciate that
kind of stuff and I'm the new Star Wars
that some of the new Star Wars is making
me helpful for because you know they
made it clear it's like they don't know
we're doing practical effects and
puppetry and all that sort of stuff
mm-hmm you know and then you have films
like interstellar that used a whole
bunch of miniatures and it seems like
neill blomkamp does like to put a lot of
real stuff in the frame and even want a
CGI it looks [ __ ] good well because
it is master the simple trick of like
you have a special effect yeah we'll
just cover it in dirt hey because then
it will take away from you know it's
like all the aliens in district 9 all
the machine really it's all dirty cuz
it's all like you know in a slum
somewhere that makes everything look so
much more real like chappies mocap but
it looks real yeah you know like he
knows how to do effects yeah and his
visual effects team knows how to do the
next yeah well anyway guys thanks for
tuning in with us if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects jerry has a show on this channel
reasons to Jerry does move your reviews
and his automobile his Lamborghini
that's not fast learners 50 miles per
hour is on the phone it's [ __ ]
ridiculous yeah like Ricky knees go 250
miles I believe it's a thousand that's
not how that works yeah they go really
they can go anywhere if they can drive
on water it's amazing but yeah check
that out hopefully movie news about
neill blomkamp because he's like one of
my favorite people right now no he's
cool and we gained crap for chappie
saying it's like a ripoff of some other
movie
supposed to be like Robocop meets et I
know but there was funnier Oh short
circuit short sir yeah that's the one
people been saying that for since they
announced the movie was getting made I'm
sure he'll add a different Flair in a
different style if you watch the [ __ ]
truth yeah exactly it's not sure
somebody's totally speaking it's a
similar in plot short but it's different
you know different plenty yeah watch
just wait TC and sigourney weaver still
looks pretty hot and she's great at
playing guns sure sure almost been a
whole video without making a comment
like that yeah I know we had so far